politicians are gaslighting americans
that's what's happening right now we
have two tweets over the weekend from a
politician who absolutely is saying
there's no way she believes this stuff
zero chance that she believes the first
tweet we have is that we elizabeth
warren tweeted and said americans are
paying record high prices for their
thanksgiving turkey while big poultry
companies are paying billions in
dividends giving ceos raises and earning
huge profits these companies are abusing
their market power i'm asking the
department of justice to investigate i
want to frame this for a second here we
live in a country that is 6.2 percent
official inflation number there's over
four and a half percent unemployment
there's 11 million open jobs last year
in 2020 was the single highest one-year
record jump in homicides in the united
states and we have a supply chain that
couldn't move a dime five feet without
incurring more cost the whole system's
broken unemployment too high inflation
too high open rolls too high homicides
up significantly and the supply chains
are broken add in that it's getting
worse and worse inflation is
accelerating and you can quickly see how
bad the situation is but while all
that's going on the people that have
been elected to leadership positions on
both sides of the aisle are absolutely
losing their minds we have a politician
who wants to use the department of
justice the department of justice to
investigate big poultry what the hell is
big culture i've never heard of big
poultry i don't think there's some big
evil corporation that is trying to stuff
chicken and turkey at overpriced uh
terms down your throat for thanksgiving
what is big poultry this is complete
nonsense
but even worse than that is the
department of justice really we're gonna
have the department of justice go
investigate the turkey companies to see
if they're selling the turkeys for too
much
well that would ask the question
why did they do it last year why did
they price gouge last year or the year
before that or the year before that why
is it that randomly the chicken poultry
and turkey companies randomly decided in
2021 this is the year we're going to get
them this year they're not going to
expect it we're going to price gouge
them
this is insane but these people don't
actually believe this they know that the
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
that we have in this country has
completely destroyed the middle class it
has ruined the purchasing power of 45
percent of americans that have no
investable assets and it has driven
prices through the roof go to a gas pump
and try to buy gas and you tell me that
something's not wrong go and try and buy
a turkey like you did for yesterday and
tell me something's not wrong it's not
price gouging it's literally they simply
are having increased labor cost and
they're having increased fixed costs and
they're having increased cost of goods
so they have to increase their prices
they have to pass it on to their
consumer
now the second tweet she had was
wondering why your thanksgiving
groceries cost more this year it's
because greedy corporations are charging
americans extra just to keep their stock
prices high this is outrageous
no what's outrageous is that actually in
many cases these businesses have given
their employees raises we've seen
everyone from chipotle down to tyson
foods all the way across they've all
given their employees races they've
increased their own costs because they
have to because that's how a free market
works is that if your competitors
increase their labor cost you have to as
well or your employees will leave and so
we have seen every corporation continue
to pay their employees more and more and
more 80
80 of americans get paid more than
fifteen dollars an hour there is no need
for politicians to pass a higher minimum
wage the free market has already
determined that the minimum wage in
america for eighty percent of american
workers is over fifteen dollars an hour
mcdonald's is paying 20
is mcdonald's price gouging as well
they're paying their employees 20
in some cases we have seen people
literally say i'll give you thousands of
dollars of a signing bonus to get a
signing bonus you used to either have to
be a professional athlete or go work on
wall street now we're giving it to fast
food workers something is wrong and it's
not because there's some greedy
corporation the corporations are doing
exactly what economics would require
them to do if my expenses go up the only
way for me to protect my profits
is for me to raise my prices so that i
keep the same margin and in many cases
i'm actually willing to bet that most of
them are making less on a percentage
basis it just so happens that at the
same time that they're increasing their
prices the government went and gave a
bunch of liquidity to the market they
gave out stimulus checks they gave out
boost to unemployment they pushed
liquidity into every single exotic
financial corner of the market and so
there's all this free cash flowing
around and so what do people do they
either hold it and lose purchasing power
or they spend it so they're rushing out
and they're spending it and they're
spending it and they're spending it you
could go sector by sector industry by
industry and everyone is experiencing
higher profits higher revenue and stock
prices going up
are they all greedy is every single
person who runs a company greece is the
small business owner who had to increase
their prices are they greedy as well
is a small business on main street that
owns literally one location has five
employees and they've had to increase
their prices 10 percent this year
because they can't source their goods
for the same prices or their labor needs
to get paid more in order to keep up
with inflation are they greedy
if our politicians want to attack our
corporations then they should be
intellectually honest because whether
you're a small business or you're a
corporation you're forced to do the
exact same thing has nothing to do with
price gouging has nothing to do with
greed and it's everything to do with
undisciplined monetary and fiscal policy
and the part that nobody wants to talk
about is they did this
the companies are just merely reaction
they're reacting to the undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy they're not
the ones who did this and anyone who's
saying that they did has lost their
minds what do you think joe
i
do not even think that she believes what
she is saying zero chance zero chance i
don't even think she wrote i think this
is classic just
throwing [ __ ] out there to cater to
her her fan base and gaslighting yeah
that's exactly what it is because she
knows everyone knows everyone that has
some simple understanding of economics
and how businesses work know that when
all these costs are increasing you have
to also they have shareholders some of
these corporations public com companies
have shareholders individual
institutional et cetera retail traders
that own parts of these companies that
demand you to keep your margins good
demand you to continue to make to make
more money when you're paying employers
more when the supply chain is messed up
when you're introducing all this
liquidity into the into the economy
30 to i think it's like 35 or 40 of the
money that is currently in circulation
was printed in the last 12 to 18 months
they know what they did they know what
the end result of this was and again
part of this is they were put in a
really difficult situation right i don't
think anyone had the perfect solution
when you're hit with a uh a virus like
covid and the economy has to shut down
you have to tell people to do all these
different things there's a million
different arguments about what they
should have done there is no one
clear-cut solution that says hey this
would have been the perfect response
they're put in a really difficult
situation but to sit there and now say
that corporations are being greedy and
trying to price gouge and do all these
things it's [ __ ] they know it's
[ __ ] and i don't even believe she
believes half of what she's saying i
think it is literally she's just
pandering to her base and trying to put
out this information to save her own
seat and say hey look they're they're
being greedy they're doing all these
things and putting the blame on other
people she as a politician knows exactly
what happened from a fundamental
understanding of business she knows
exactly what happened i think this is
all [ __ ] john what do you think to
see a u.s senator elizabeth warren
saying stuff like this is it's just not
good like it's it's literally trying to
fuel the american people to think one
way and if you say things enough people
begin to believe that it is true when
this is just not what's going on
restaurants for example the cost of
people has gone up the cost of food has
gone up the cost of rent has gone up and
these corporations they're not price
gouging to increase their stock price
you know what's increasing their stock
price when you print trillions and
trillions of dollars in the last 18
months and stocks are just going up
they're going through the roof they
don't need the price gouge to do that
their margins are actually getting
squeezed because of the cost that
they're incurring and
i think that once these costs go up for
certain items they're not going to go
back down you see chipotle increase
their cost by what four percent across
the board basically stakes up 20
it's around 20 stake from last year to
this year's up over 20
so as a restaurant they're actually i
think their margins are getting squeezed
even more and they're just trying to do
what they can to stay afloat i don't
think they're necessarily price gouging
but they also run a corporation if you
don't want to eat there you don't have
to eat there that is the beauty of the
free market and what we live in today
the last thing i'm going to say about
this and then we're going to bring on
the uh first person who bought a
thousand dollars worth of merch what
hyperinflation's incoming no no even
better
you know the part that they'll never
admit
the federal government increased pay
they voted this year in the senate
appropriators said yes we're gonna
increase pay for federal workers next
year which by the way is a good thing
that's a good thing we should we should
say yes that's good they only did a 2.2
percent which means that they literally
aren't even keeping up with inflation
which is a whole other argument of
literally the federal government's gonna
pay federal workers less next year than
they are this year big problem
but now should we say that the
government's greedy the government is
literally increasing their cost uh
they're greedy they're greedy they're
taking more of our money they're taking
more than our taxpayer money to go in to
pay their staff
you greedy leaders the the the thing
that i would say is like don't trust any
of them whatever side of the aisle you
think you stand on don't trust any of
them what we have found over time is uh
these people are always going to do what
is in the best interest of themselves
because that's what the incentives
reward and i think ultimately the best
decision is not to trust any of them and
and don't stick your head in the sand
and say hey i agree with this party on
one issue or on all issues you need to
look at everything kind of in a silo and
say hey let's take the facts for what
they are and decide from there because
if we found anything politicians will
lie to you that's what they'll do and
and not everyone is in it for your best
interest one of the best things was mark
cuban when he was talking about bitcoin
and specifically and he was just like
look i read or uh i think it was gary
vee actually they basically read
all the negative stuff and what people
were kind of rebuking about and like
what they were saying to understand the
entire argument of all this and that's
what i think you're kind of getting to
is like you have to look at both sides
because then you get a clearer picture
and then you can make your own opinion
rather than just reading one side of
saying hey inflation's going up because
of this this this you want to look at
everything and make your own opinion